tras ganar la Euro a Alemania y la
finalísima a las campeonas sudamericanas
de Brasil la selección femenina de
Inglaterra tiene otro trofeo en la mira
para este verano esta vez será lejos de
casa en la copa mundial en Australia y
Nueva Zelanda las inglesas ocupan el
puesto 4 en el ranking de la FIFA y se
clasificaron ganando los días partidos
de eliminatorias estas cifras ubican a
las dirigidas por Sabrina como uno de
los equipos favoritos el equipo está en
plena mutación tras el retiro de algunas
jugadoras ciertas dudas sobre el nivel
físico de otras y la llegada de nuevas
caras como neam Charles saguera central
del Chelsea Qué espera ser una de las 23
convocadas
creo que viendo lo que ha sido este
último año es algo muy emocionante creo
que sabemos que será algo muy grande
para el fútbol femenino y para inspirar
a más Niñas estamos muy orgullosos de
todo esto
las leonas se coronaron campeonas de la
Euro 2022 justo cuando se cumplían 50
años del primer partido internacional
femenil en Inglaterra tras el fin de la
prohibición del fútbol femenino en el
país mucho ha cambiado desde entonces
este año el promedio de asistencia de la
superliga femenina ha aumentado en un
200%
los hinchas continúan viniendo hemos
notado un incremento importante de los
hinchas que ven la superliga femenina
nuestros partidos del Campeonato y creo
también que hemos visto un aumento en el
interés comercial a nivel general en lo
que atañe al fútbol femenino Así que
creo que en todos los frentes esto ha
sido un verdadero catalizador para el
cambio este interés también se ha
traducido por más niñas que quieren
jugar al fútbol varias de las jugadoras
de esta escuela en el sur de Londres Se
inscribieron en el último año
nos inspira mucho el hecho de que las
mujeres hayan ganado la Euro vimos cada
uno de los partidos que jugaron y fue de
verdad genial las leonas no Solo han
inspirado también han logrado cambios
concretos gracias a ellas las niñas como
las que juegan Aquí tienen más
oportunidades de practicar el fútbol y
otros deportes en el colegio y esto es
gracias a una campaña liderada por la
selección inglesa que tras llevarsela a
Euro logró que el gobierno británico
anunciara un proyecto de 600 millones de
libras para dar más recursos a las
mujeres en este deporte